yeah welcome to this video playing tiger
print erosion okay does he have a name
Marco money and yeah I played him before
so going for a French defence doing a
little bit something different here okay
is going for this pawn sec line that I'm
not really up for with Queen B 6 the
milliner Barry it's not a particularly
great porn sex but I always played like
that here this line which is quite quite
simple and also quite good here white
has given up the light squared Bishop
for no particular compensation so I
already like my position quite a bit
hairy let's see this night is going to
be useful on the on the queenside only
issue as usual in the fringes the lack
of space let's see maybe we should be 7
to start if he goes tonight f4 he
doesn't hmm ok so i'm simply i'm going
to castle
yeah not going to get checkmated there
on g7 don't don't believe that so let's
see how do you do hear about the screen
be six maybe queen be 60 a special g5
that's that's a possibility
Jim when problem is he always wants to
put something on g5 which my bishop and
queen have to protect somehow that's a
bit awkward if he gets in Bishop g5
really is that's nothing I think
terribly problematic but I don't want
him to trade this bishop
and Joe maybe there's nothing else that
I can do I mean Bishop g5 now 195 is
possible and I g5 not that much that
would drop deform i think for real so
it's not really going for any of that
that's surprising okay Bishop a three he
has 95 that's not a good idea but this
should trade quite quite a bit of a firm
of material Jack I'm not checkmated here
quickly I will have a good good endgame
maybe takes takes bishop h6 as a move
okay that could be could be on check and
that could be on bishop age 60 m that's
may be possible my Kings King safety is
not really that great Pusha page six
yeah I am that's possible let's move
it's definitely a move and I at least
cannot take it okay yeah I can go back
from the moment but knight Knight f6
might be possible I'd have six I have
king age eight ok let's go back first
and then see what happens if you give
this chick here there's also maybe
that's not on right at six King edge
eight he has no great follow-up I think
what am i doing if he's playing a slow
can I go Queen a5 checking a to just to
maybe win a temple yeah that that's
that's a possibility definitely but i
think i can go age 6 cm covering
covering v5 or not i think i can
you can try Queen f4 between f/4g for
what I have g6 it is it is still but
it's the resilient I think ok so what
about Quincy six if he goes in Queens
you for I'm checkmating him she cannot
sacrifice directly it's always made down
c1 my ideas to get it Quincy for to g6
as a way to to defend
Queen g6 or 24 those kind of moves would
help quite a bit I don't see something
direct here if you maybe you can take
twice there yes that's may be possible
taking taking twice Queen f6 check for a
draw or more I don't know okay chicken
now that I don't believe that that that
looks to two fantastic let's see um
Queen check and Queen f5 check one I
need to take h5 was check this is why I
had to check be one first now i'm taking
on 93 is also good right come on let's
get this night into the game for Queen
f4 trading Queens that piece sex was
just not working
quite resigned yeah I was under some
pressure definitely maybe there was
something i was more worried here um
when when we got here that check was
more worried about be sure change 6 yeah
that's also what the computer gives
bishop age 6 that looked a bit more more
dangerous to me I don't really know what
i'm going to play now and wide wins and
maybe I can try try something like that
try to in a way win it win a tempo here
on the queen she can go back yeah this
is a line that challenge and is given
chaff my king is in terrible shape yeah
Bishop h6 was probably rather strong
young I don't really see what to do in
defense yeah it's also this it's also
something that the comp is suggesting
that I think is actually interesting
because well let's say here maybe I'm I
mean an endgame a porn down this maybe
not totally busted because I have some
play against the Queen side but yeah I'm
thinking about think about this here I
need something like this I don't know
and this is kind of far off yeah it's
not enough for porn yeah Bishop h6 was
strong yeah this is this was a bit his
most tricky it was really tricky and
this is position maybe I am I shouldn't
shouldn't have played Queen to be 6
I oh ok that's a very good computer
suggestion Queen B 5 trying to trade
yeah it's very very strong actually
winning twinning 10pm because he doesn't
want to trade in case of a trade my two
bishops will be great so what has to
move the Queen and hear ya here I've
gained a little bit yeah with my queen
now an a5 and yeah i can think of ways
to improve now i don't know Bishop e3 is
probably risky not but interesting yeah
this is probably what I should have done
check so j-20 head bishop age six but
didn't go for it and here this is not
this is not s s clear quince is six yeah
h foil the computer gives this line also
I'm Queens the 2 i'm not sure if i would
have found that one why can i not just
take this is the draw all right this is
probably a catch earlier with queen here
so this is a perpetual maybe i would
have done that this is stronger though
Jim look at this this check check and
now I have chance like this to avoid the
perpetual wow this is what you did
Quincy to chiggs try and check this is
this is ending the whole business now
that was a was a tough game Bishop h6
was a very very strong frame I guess
okay well thanks for watching